Gente, vocês não vão acreditar no que eu
vi outro dia. Youtuber famoso soltou
essa pérola. Chocolate amargo é pior que
chocolate ao leite porque tem mais
gordura saturada. Quando eu vi isso, eu
quase caí da cadeira. Vamos desmascarar
esse mito de uma vez por todas. Primeiro
vamos aos fatos. Peguei os dados da
tabela brasileira de composição de
alimentos que chama-se taco. A sigla é a
nossa bíblia nutricional aqui do Brasil.
E adivinhe? O chocolate ao leite tem em
média 17.5
g de gordura saturada por 100 g. Já o
chocolate meio amargo tem 13,1 g. Opa,
pera aí. O que que o youtuber tava
falando é o contrário da realidade. Mas
sabe o que é mais interessante? A
gordura do chocolate amargo vem
principalmente da manteiga de cacau, que
tem um perfil bem diferente das gorduras
animais. É rica em ácido esteeárico, que
o nosso corpo converte em ácido oleico,
o mesmo do azeite de oliva. Então, nem
toda gordura saturada é criada igual,
OK? E tem mais, o chocolate amargo é uma
potência nutricional, é uma potência
antioxidante. Quanto mais cacau, mais
polifenóis, aqueles antioxidantes
maravilhosos que combatem os radicais
livres. Tem flavonoides, tem minerais
como magnésio, ferro, potássio. É
praticamente um suplemento maravilhoso,
além de ser saboroso na minha opinião.
Ah, mas doutor, então posso comer
chocolate amargo à vontade? Calma lá,
minha gente. O chocolate ainda é
calórico, tem entre 450 e 650 calorias
por 100 g. A recomendação é consumir
cerca de 30 g por dia. Isso dá uns
quatro quadradinhos. E de preferência
chocolate com pelo menos 70% de cacau e
com bons ingredientes e com mínimo ou
sem açúcar, se for possível. O chocolate
ao leite, coitado, além de ter mais
gordura saturada, tem muito mais açúcar
e muito menos cacau. Às vezes tem só 25%
de cacau. O resto é açúcar, leite em pó
e outras coisas. E é gostoso? É, para
muitas pessoas é, mas nutritivo que é
bom não é. Sabe o que me deixa mais
indignado? É ver informação errada sendo
espalhada por aí. As pessoas confiam
nesses influencers e acabam fazendo as
coisas ruins paraa saúde. Por isso é tão
importante checar as fontes, pesquisar,
questionar. Não é porque alguém tem
milhões de seguidores que sabe do que tá
falando. Então, da próxima vez que
alguém vier com essa conversa de que
chocolate amargo é pior, você já sabe, é
fake news nutricional. Chocolate amar
com moderação pode sim fazer parte de
uma alimentação saudável. Ainda por cima
aumenta serotonina, melhor humor é
ciência, minha gente.